in its first weekend beta tests call  duty modern warfare introduced a new  realism mode this multiplayer mode mixes  aspects from the series core and  hardcore play styles it removes the  mini-map compass kill feed and hit  markers from the HUD when equipment is  ready to use a small white dot will  appear on the bottom right hand side of  the screen when firing at an enemy the  lack of hit markers makes it more  difficult to determine a confirmed kill  like regular core modes the match starts  with 100 health however it only takes a  single headshot from any gun to down an  enemy staying off the radar is the most  crucial in this mode so have the rocket  launcher class ready and make sure you  abies are equipped what do you think of  this new mode let us know down in the  comments and see for yourself how a  match of realism mode unfolds  [Music]  a light display  you  [Music]